Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. We will make you Khan. You shall ride at our head against our foes. We will throw ourselves like lightning on your enemies. We will bring you their finest women and girls, their rich tents like palaces. Those were the chieftains of the Mongols speaking to...
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们将奉你为汗。你将率领我们迎战敌人。我们将如闪电般扑向你们的仇敌。我们将为你带来他们最美的妇女和女孩，以及如宫殿般富丽堂皇的帐篷。这是蒙古首领们在对……
What was that? Is that a mongolian accent yeah have you not been to mongolia tom i haven't no i had no idea that's what they said so you're not familiar uh with the mongolian accent as i am i mean i haven't been to mong but you know i've done it um okay very impressive yeah so so ali as you recognise, that was a really quite sensitive and very appropriate rendition. I wasn't in any way orientalising. I was convinced. Yeah, of the Mongol chieftains speaking to Genghis Khan or Chinggis Khan. Chinggis. Yeah, when he becomes...
那是什么？那是蒙古口音吗？是的。汤姆，你没去过蒙古吗？我没去过，没有。我完全不知道他们说的是这个。所以你对蒙古口音不像我那么熟悉？我的意思是，我没去过蒙——但你知道的，我模仿过。嗯，好吧，非常令人印象深刻。是的，所以——所以，阿里，如你所认同的，那是一个相当敏感且非常贴切的演绎。我绝没有将其“东方主义化”。我很信服。是的，蒙古首领们在对成吉思汗或成吉思汗说话。成吉思。是的，当他成为……
It's like when he becomes Ulaanbaatar. It is. When he becomes their paramount leader. So welcome back to our second episode on Genghis Khan. We are, of course, joined again by Ali Ansari. So, Ali, to kick off, a question from Mark Woodhouse. What on earth was Genghis Khan trying to achieve? What on earth was Genghis Khan trying to achieve? I think basically his destiny was really to, I mean, this is the interesting thing. So if you consider his title to be Lord of all those who dwelt and felt tense, his ambition really was to bring all the nomads under his control. And then China, which was normally their number one target, was the place you plunder to keep everyone happy and bring the, it's not really a question of immediately of conquest, although what you do see with Genghis Khan is this desire for ultimately to take over these areas.
就像他成为乌兰巴托一样。确实如此。当他成为他们的最高领袖。欢迎回到我们关于成吉思汗的第二期节目。当然，阿里·安萨里也再次加入了我们。所以，阿里，我们先从马克·伍德豪斯的一个问题开始。成吉思汗到底想达成什么？成吉思汗到底想达成什么？我认为基本上他的命运确实是——我的意思是，这就是有趣的地方。如果你认为他的称号是“所有居住并感受帐篷之人的领主”，那么他的野心实际上是将所有游牧民族置于他的控制之下。然后中国，通常是他们的头号目标，是一个你可以去大肆掠夺以让每个人开心、并带来……这其实并不是一个立即征服的问题，尽管你在成吉思汗身上确实看到了这种最终接管这些地区的渴望。
But the standard, you know, the standard nomad warlord modus operandi is, you know, you bring all these tribal groups together and then you go and plunder the Chinese. I mean, that's basically that's that's what you do and um i think i mean were his ambitions obviously you know in retrospect and with the benefit of hindsight it was to be ruler of the world um i think at the time it's basically this notion if you accept that title that he would be ruler of all those on the plains on the steps and then obviously china is the place you go and sort of have a bit of fun so essentially he's become paramount leader and he needs to keep his men happy. Yes.
但标准的，你知道的，标准游牧军阀的行事方式就是，你知道，你把所有这些部落聚集在一起，然后你去掠夺中国人。我的意思是，这基本上就是——这就是你所做的。而且我认为——我是说他的野心显然，你知道，在回顾过去和事后诸葛亮的情况下，是成为世界之王……我认为在当时，这基本上是一种观念：如果你接受了这个称号，你将成为平原和草原上所有人的统治者，然后很显然，中国就是那个你去享受一番乐趣的地方。所以本质上，他成为了最高领袖，他需要让他的手下满意。是的。
And you keep them happy by providing them with plunder. So initially his aim is just to get plunder, but he finds he's so good at the whole conquering thing that his horizon start to expand. I think there's definitely an element of that. Yeah. There's definitely an element of that where, you know,
而你通过为他们提供战利品来让他们满意。所以最初他的目标只是获得战利品，但他发现自己非常擅长征服这件事，以至于他的视野开始开阔了。我认为这绝对包含了一部分因素。是的。这绝对包含了一部分因素，你知道，
you sort of feel goodness, this is actually turning out rather well. And, you know, let's keep going. So, I mean, initially, you know, what he does is he attacks those parts of the Chinese Imperium that are basically closest to the nomadic, you know, the northern Chinese kingdoms. And then he moves to the, if I've got the name right, I think the Qin dynasty in the north where you have where modern Peking and other places are. And that's his focus. So he's he's basically declared Genghis Khan in 1206. And, you know, for the next 14 years or so, his focus is on China. I mean, that's what he's up to. So there are two great kingdoms, aren't there? There's the Tanguts, the Western Zhizhi. Zhizhi, yeah. Basically, he kind of reduces them to a tributary status. Yeah, yeah. And then the Qin, who basically he's going after.
你会觉得，天哪，这其实进展得挺顺利。而且，你知道，让我们继续。所以，我的意思是，最初，你知道，他所做的是攻击中国帝国中基本上最接近游牧民族的那部分，也就是中国北方王国。然后他转向——如果我没记名错的话——北方的金朝，也就是现代北京和其他地方所在的地方。这就是他的焦点。所以他在1206年基本上被宣称为成吉思汗。而且，你知道，在接下来的14年左右里，他的焦点都在中国。我的意思是，这就是他在忙的事情。所以有两个伟大的王国，对吧？一个是党项人，即西夏。西夏，是的。基本上，他把他们降为了纳贡国。对，对。然后是金朝，基本上是他的攻击目标。
But as I said, the interesting thing is he has less success initially in reducing the cities because it's quite difficult. You know, they're not as competent at dealing with, you know. But the Qin, the Qin, the Qin, the Qin Emperor. So chin the chin the chin emperor so the tanglets are being attacked by the mongols by gingis khan yeah and they send a messenger to the chin saying please would you come and help us yeah um and they reply it works to our benefit where our enemies attack each other how does it endanger us yeah exactly which as a kind of geopolitical judgment is not the best well this, this is the thing. Of course, in previous times, it would have worked.
但正如我所说，有趣的地方在于，他最初在攻陷城市方面的成功较小，因为这相当困难。你知道的，他们在处理……方面没那么熟练。但是金朝，金朝，金朝皇帝。所以金朝皇帝，党项人正遭到蒙古人、成吉思汗的攻击，是的。他们派使者去对金朝说：“请你们来帮帮我们吧。”是的。他们的回应是：“这符合我们的利益，当我们的敌人互相攻击时，这怎么会危及我们呢？”是的，完全如此。作为一种地缘政治判断，这并不是最佳的选择。嗯，这就是问题所在。当然，在过去，这会起作用。
I mean, the idea is we'll support whichever, we'll create dissension. What they miscalculate, of course, in this case, is that Genghis Khan is of a different caliber of leader. So, yes, that's a miscalculation, I think, on their part on this occasion. But the question then is so as tom tom said you know he needs to deliver plunder and loot for his yeah for his men basically it's a way of
我的意思是，我们的想法是支持无论哪一方，我们将制造分歧。当然，他们在这个案子中误算的是，成吉思汗是不同水准的领袖。所以，是的，我认为他们在这次事件中是一个误算。但随之而来的问题是——正如汤姆·汤姆所说，你知道，他需要为他的手下提供战利品和劫掠，基本上这是一种
keeping them together it's a way of keeping his own popularity but do you think there's a at this stage there's anything you know you said it was 14 years is there any any moment where he has thought you know what actually i could go i could go further i could become an empire builder rather than just an empire looter or do you think he was i think he does no i think he does i think as he finds success in northern china i mean i think he does become you know his idea of being an empire builder certainly that now one one of the things you know one of the debates that you have and it's in the secret history and it's in the persian histories is this idea of jengis khan as a law giver you know yeah this idea of the great Yasa of Genghis Khan.
把他们团结在一起的方式，也是维持他个人声望的一种方式。但你认为在这个阶段，有什么——正如你所说那是14年——有没有哪个时刻，他曾想过：“你知道吗，其实我可以走得更远，我可以成为一个帝国的建设者，而不仅仅是一个帝国的掠夺者”？或者你认为他——我认为他有，不，我认为他有。我认为当他在中国北方取得成功时，我的意思是，我认为他确实成为了——他成为帝国建设者的想法，当然现在——你知道，其中一个辩论是，它在《蒙古秘史》和波斯史料中都有记载，这就是将成吉思汗视为立法者的观点，你知道，是的，关于成吉思汗伟大《扎撒》（Yasa）的这种观点。
Of course, there's huge debate among historians about whether this existed. I mean, nobody knows whether Genghis Khan had a Yasa. But it's this idea that certainly in retrospect, they apply this to him. He's a great lawgiver. And it's part of the way in which his image has slightly been softened. But there's no actual evidence, actually, that this great law code existed during his lifetime. So, again, it's this sort of idea of whether he had a plan or whether it was, oh, this is going rather well. So I will now have a plan, you know.
当然，历史学家们对于这是否真实存在有着巨大的争论。我的意思是，没有人知道成吉思汗是否真的有一部《扎撒》。但这是一种观点，即当然在事后看来，人们将这一点套用在了他身上。他是一位伟大的立法者。这也是他的形象被稍微柔化的方式的一部分。但实际上并没有实际证据表明这部伟大的法典在他有生之年真的存在过。所以，再次重申，这是一种关于他当时究竟是有个计划，还是只是觉得：“哦，这进展得挺不错，那我现在就制定个计划吧”的想法。
But so you say, is this about the script as well? Because he devises a script, doesn't he? Well, again, it's a matter of, you know, the secret history is written in a sort of Uyghur script. Much I have to say to the absolute contempt of Persian historians who think this is the utmost act of vulgarity, I'm sorry to say.
但你刚才说，这跟文字也有关吗？因为他设计了一种文字，对吧？嗯，再次重申，这是一个关于……你知道，《蒙古秘史》是用某种回鹘文（Uyghur script）写的。我必须说，这令波斯历史学家们感到无比鄙视，他们认为这是极其粗俗的行为，请原谅我直言。
But, I mean, this script, so it derives ultimately via the Uyghurs from the Sogdians from Aramaic,, ultimately back to Hebrew. I mean, it's kind of an amazing, amazing thought that this script in Mongolia comes all the way from, you know, has this incredibly kind of lengthy genealogy. But are you saying that the stories that Genghis Khan recognising that he needs lords and that lords will require a script, that this is not true? This is not actually true. It's a matter of some... I mean, people say there's no evidence
但是，我的意思是，这种文字，它最终通过回鹘人从粟特人那里演变而来，再追溯到阿拉姆语，最终追溯到希伯来语。我的意思是，这真是一个令人惊叹、不可思议的想法：蒙古的这种文字竟然一路来自……你知道，有着如此令人难以置信的漫长谱系。但你是说，成吉思汗意识到他需要贵族，而贵族需要文字的这些故事，其实并不是真的？这其实并不是真的。这是一个……我的意思是，人们说根本没有证据
of it actually existing at the time. I mean, this is the problem. It's part of the, I suppose, the rehabilitation of the wrong term. But, you know, you're trying to... You're almost trying to turn Genghis Khan into some sort of enlightened despot. Yeah.
证明它当时真的存在。我的意思是，这就是问题所在。这可以说是某种……重塑，虽然用词不太准确。但你知道，你是在试图……你几乎是在试图把成吉思汗塑造成某种开明专制君主。是的。
He's a lawgiver. So I reviewed this book called fake history last year right in which they referred to him throughout as khan and oh dear and uh in that it basically said it said that genghis we'd all got completely the wrong idea about khan because he was um he was very enlightened he was a liberal i'd used the words i said it was very inclusive and diverse and all that kind of thing so basically madden made him sound like i don't know um sir ed davy the leader of the liberal democrats i mean you know a lot of these we've had these discussions before you know a lot of this is sort of transplanting our modern notions
他是一位立法者。所以我去年评论了一本书叫《虚假历史》，对吧？他们在书中自始至终称他为“汗”，噢天哪，而且——在书中基本上说，成吉思汗——我们对“汗”完全产生了错误的理解，因为他非常开明，他是个自由主义者。我当时用了这些词，我说他非常包容、多元化以及诸如此类的一切。所以基本上，这让他听起来就像——我不知道——自由民主党领袖埃德·戴维爵士（Sir Ed Davey）。我的意思是，你知道，我们以前也讨论过很多次：这其中很大一部分是将我们对政治领袖含义的现代观念，
of of what it means to be a political leader back into them you know and who is doing that who's doing who's doing this is it the chinese is it the mongolians is it well i think the mongolian academics i mean ever since the mongolian you know ever since you know uh that was quite interesting i mean i when i studied this back at university of course it was it was um i hesitate to say this now to reveal all sorts of but you know before the fall of the iron curtain so you know it was before mongolia really sort of came out into the light and of course then you know what the mongolians did is they wanted to sort of like emphasize just what a wonderful character chengis khan was he's the father of the nation you see so you know you get this sort of came out into the light and of course then you know what the mongolians did is they wanted to sort of like emphasize just what a wonderful character chengis khan was he's the father of the nation you see so you know you get this sort of reinvention of him really and um a lot of protests obviously from people saying you know how dare you you know criticize him for being
强加到他们身上，你知道。是谁在这么做？是谁在做这件事？是中國人吗？是蒙古人吗？还是……嗯，我认为是蒙古学者。自从蒙古……自从，你知道，嗯——那挺有趣的。当我在大学里学习这段历史时，当然，那是——我 hesitant（犹豫）现在说这个，以免暴露各种……但你知道，那是在铁幕倒塌之前。所以，你知道，那是在蒙古真正走向光明之前。当然，后来你知道蒙古人做的是，他们想要强调成吉思汗是一个多么美好的人物。他是国父，你看。所以，你知道，你会看到对他的这种……走向光明之前。当然，后来你知道蒙古人做的是，他们想要强调成吉思汗是一个多么美好的人物。他是国父，你看。所以，你会看到对他的这种……重新塑造，真的。而且，显然有很多人抗议说：“你怎么敢批评他更残暴一些，或者也许他——他其实是一个非常非常正派的家伙。”嗯，我的意思是，这的问题在于它完全不符合历史。这根本不是他当时看待事物的方式。他显然是一个比他的许多对手要成熟得多的政治操盘手。否则，他不可能取得这样的成功。但我不认为他对……如果有必要的话，他会把你煮了。好吧，或者大肆屠杀。
um you know somewhat more brutal or perhaps you know uh he's you know he was actually a very very sort of decent chap well i mean the problem with that is it's completely ahistorical. That's just not how he would have basically seen it. He clearly was a much more sophisticated political operator than many of his rivals. Otherwise, he wouldn't have succeeded the way he did. But I don't think he had any qualms about... He'd boil you if he had to. Well, or massacre you.
嗯，我们都知道这一点，不是吗？因为我认为这是真实的，他——我的意思是，他已经迫使党项人屈服了，是的，并且在经过一番漫长的过程后最终攻占了北京，是的，来自波斯世界的使者来到这里，是的，他们参观了曾经是北京的地方，他们说那里的泥土被人类的油脂浸得油腻。没错。他们的随从中有人生病了，因为有太多腐烂的尸体。那种原本是一座城市的废墟上堆满无数尸体的情景。
Well, we know this, don't we? Because I think that this is authentic that he i mean he's reduced the tangos to submission yeah and he does end up taking beijing yeah after kind of a lengthy process and ambassadors come from the persian world yeah and they visit what had been beijing and they say that the soil is greasy with human fat. That's right. And that some of their train fall sick because there are so many rotting bodies. And that sense of great piles of the dead littering what had originally been a city.
我的意思是，这大概不是凭空捏造的。这背后一定有一些事实依据。我的意思是，这大概不是凭空捏造的。这背后一定有一些事实依据。我的意思是，这就是有趣的地方。如果你仔细观察，它在很大程度上——你是从许多当时写作的波斯历史学家那里获取信息的。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的……从历史的角度来看，回到我们之前的话题，这是波斯历史学家真正大放异彩的时期。我的意思是，这有点像一场巨大的危机，他们所有人都必须写点东西，然后说：“这到底是怎么发生的？”但从这些记载中可以非常清楚地看出，他们对暴力的规模感到真正的震惊。我的意思是，他们被震惊了。现在，很明显他们夸大了，你知道的，他们谈到数以百万计的人遭到屠杀诸如此类的事情。当然，这——你知道，人们会对此不屑一顾，认为对于中亚城市和其他地方以及呼罗珊来说，这有多大真实性？但我认为这是一个很好的唤起，说明他们对暴力规模感到多么的心烦意乱。而且，当然，另一件事是，蒙古人的暴力并非不分青红皂白，这倒也是真的——从某种意义上说，如果你投降了，那就没事了。
I mean, presumably not invented from nothing. There must be some basis of fact for this. I mean, that not invented from nothing. There must be some basis of fact for this. I mean, that's the interesting thing. If you look at it, it is largely, you take it from many of the Persian historians that are writing at the time. I mean, it's a great, you know, from a historical point of view, going back to our previous encounter, this is the great flourishing of Persian historians, actually. I mean, it's sort of like a great crisis and they all have to write something and say, how the hell did this happen? But it's quite clear from the accounts that they're truly shocked at the scale of the violence. I mean, they are shocked. Now, obviously, they exaggerate, you know, they're talking about millions and millions of people being massacred and this sort of thing. And obviously, that's, you know, people will dismiss that in terms of, you know, how realistic is that for Central Asian cities and others and Khorasan. But I think it's a good evocation of how distressed they were about the scale of the violence. And, you know, of course, the other thing is, it is quite true that Mongol violence was not indiscriminate in the sense that if you submitted, it was fine.
你知道，但如果你不投降，那就相当不分青红皂白了。我的意思是，就是这样。而且，而且，你知道，对此没有任何妥协。因此，这些中世纪历史学家——如果我可以这样称呼他们的——他们自己对这种规模感到惊恐，（汤姆引用的那段话完全正确）。我实际上读过——我想那是关于中亚的某处，实际上是在呼罗珊，他们谈到在他们以为是……嗯，实际上他们以为是其他东西的东西中跋涉，然后那实际上是那些骨头堆积起来，基本上已经变成了残渣。你知道，他们描述遭遇这些情景的方式真的非常荒诞。这……你知道，它清楚地表达了——甚至在他们那个时代，他们也觉得
You know, but if you didn't submit, it was pretty indiscriminate. I mean, that's the thing. So and and and you know there was no compromise on this so the fact that these medieval historians if i can put it that way are themselves horrified at the scale and you know tom's quote is absolutely right i actually read i think it was one of the central asian i mean actually in horasan where they talk about you know sludging through what they thought was well actually what they thought was something else you know and then it's actually the sort of molding you know the bones that have been sort of basically uh uh effectively going into mulch effect you know it's it's really quite grotesque the way they describe it what they've encountered um it's uh you know it it clearly expresses a um something that even for their time they found
相当令人震惊。金朝的撤退。所以他们来自满洲，这就是为什么他们的首都位于北京。他们南下开封。那是他们的首都所在地。中国南方的南宋，目前尚未受到触动。是的，那是下一代的事。而此时，成吉思汗向西派遣了使者。他确实派了。
quite shocking the The Qin retreat. So they've come from Manchuria, which is why their capital is Beijing. They go down to Kaifeng. That's where it becomes their capital. The Song Dynasty in the south of China, they're as yet untouched. Yeah, that's for the next generation. And at this point, Genghis sends ambassadors westwards. He does.
不是吗？试图就贸易协议进行某种谈判。嗯，他先派了商队。而商队基本上受到了粗暴对待。所以跟我们聊聊这个。跟我们讲讲关于——因为那是一个庞大的国家，对吧？是的，花剌子模沙朝（Khwarazm Shahs）基本上是——如果我没记错的话——塞尔柱帝国的继承者。从某种意义上说，它基本上是一个伊朗王朝。这是一个伊朗王朝，但不得不说，并不是一个很好的王朝。现在，这里有两个主要人物。一个是穆罕默德沙，他实际上是国王。另一个是他的儿子，非常有趣，名叫扎兰丁（Jalal ad-Din）。在史书记载中，扎兰丁实际上被刻画得相当具有英雄主义色彩，显然成吉思汗相当尊重他，因为他战斗——我的意思是，当他的父亲——他的父亲基本上逃跑了，我的意思是，他几乎立刻就逃跑了，但是
Does he not? To try and kind of negotiate trading agreements. Well, he sends merchants first. And the merchants are basically roughly treated. So talk us through that. Tell us a bit about the – because there's a big state, isn't there? Yeah, the Khwarazm Shahs are basically a successor, essentially, to the – if I'm not mistaken, the Seljuks. It's basically an Iranian dynasty, if I can put it that way. And it's an Iranian dynasty, but not a very good one, it has to be said. Now, there are two characters in this. There's Mohammad Shah, who's actually the king. There's his son, who's very interesting, Jalal ad-Din. And Jalal ad-Din is actually portrayed quite heroically in the in the accounts and apparently Genghis Khan quite respects him because he fights I mean he he fights when his father his father basically runs I mean he runs almost immediately but
本质上发生的事情是，这些商人们进来了。我想一个当地总督说：“你们这群人全都是间谍，你知道的，”然后基本上我认为处决了他们中的相当一部分人。无论如何，这显然是绝对不行的。这很有可能他们确实是间谍。我的意思是，这就是另一回事了。这是一个争论的问题。成吉思汗究竟只是去调查贸易路线吗？有可能，但是，你知道，他的行事方式略有不同。就像莉兹·特拉斯（Liz Truss）一样。
essentially what happens these merchants come in I think a local governor says you know you lot are all spies you know and basically I think executes quite a few of them anyway this is obviously a no-no I, it's very possible they were spies. I mean, this is the other thing. I mean, it's a matter of debate. Was Genghis Khan simply going to investigate trade routes? Possibly, but, you know, his modus operandi was somewhat different. The Liz Truss.
我的意思是，你知道，我并不是想对此表现得愤世嫉俗，但归根结底，你知道，他可能也打算利用这些情报。但很明显，花剌子模沙朝以及他们的总督们的反应极其鲁莽。他们随后派遣了使者——一、两个蒙古使者和一个穆斯林……我想是那个穆斯林使者被处决了，因为他们说：“你知道，你们在蒙古使馆到底在搞什么鬼？”然后他们又被遣返回国。现在，这就是你听到“东方风暴”这个概念的由来，因为成吉思汗随后在1219年左右——我想是的——组织了他所掌握的有史以来规模最大的军队。
I mean, you know, again, I don't want to be cynical about it, but at the end of the day, you know, he probably was also going to use information. But obviously, the reaction of the Khuras and shahs was and their governors was extremely reckless they then sent ambassadors one two uh mongol ambassadors and a muslim um i think it's the muslim one who's actually executed because they say you know what the hell are you doing you know at the mongol embassy and they're sent back again and this now this is where you get the concept of the storm from the east by the way because what jengenghis Khan then does around 1219, I think it is. He then organizes the largest army he'd ever had actually under his control.
大约有10万人。所以，10个万户（tumen），10万人，当然包括重骑兵、轻骑兵，全套配置。我的意思是，我们对蒙古军队的印象全都是弓箭手，但并非如此——他们当中有相当一部分是身披重甲的骑兵战士。所以他们也带来了他们拥有的攻城器械，现在他们把这些东西也拉进来了。这些人大概并非全都是蒙古人吧？不，完全不是。我的意思是，很显然吸纳了各种其他人，你知道，基本的部落联盟、帝国扩张带来了各种人。所以我想实际上真正的蒙古人可能只占少数。所以中国人——没那么多，我不确定是否有。他有一个中国顾问，对吧？他确实有。他有那个著名的中国顾问。我的意思是，他们确实有攻城——我不记得他的名字了。
It's about 100,000. So 10, two months, 100,000, including obviously heavy cavalry, the light cavalry, the whole works. I mean, we have this image of the Mongolongol army being all archers and but they're not quite a lot of them are heavily armored you know the warriors on horseback so they're bringing all the siege engines too that they've got now they're bringing stuff in yeah and these people are presumably not all mongols no not at all no i mean it's obviously picked up all sorts of other you know all the the basic tribal confederacy the the imperial expansion brings in so i think actually mongols proper are probably a minority so chinese um not so much i'm not sure about there would be some siege he has a chinese advisor doesn't he he does he has the famous chinese advisor who he does have i mean they do have siege you know i can't remember his name
他留着长胡子，我想他被称为……他们所有人其实都有这些伟大的名字。因此，对中亚然后是呼罗珊的这场入侵，可能是最具毁灭性的。我的意思是，它造成了巨大的破坏。而且，它实际上是一次大规模的惩罚性远征。我的意思是，当他攻占布哈拉时，有一个精彩的记载，他最初前往中心……其实，让我稍微收回一点。所以，花剌子模沙朝在某种程度上侮辱了成吉思汗之后，接着决定不值得与他在战场上交战，因为这有点令人担忧。于是他退守到自己的城市、城堡等等。这主意真糟。我的意思是，非常糟糕的主意。他困在自己的地方，然后基本上逃跑了。他的儿子其实进行了一些战斗，但最终被击败，并逃往了印度，实际上是以一种非常戏剧性的方式。但成吉思汗在攻占布哈拉时所做的是，朱韦尼（Juvaini）的著作中有关于他的著名记载——特别是他走上布哈拉的宣礼塔，在攻占该城之后。他发表了一段这样的言论，他说，你知道，基本上——这是对穆斯林的申斥：“你们犯罪了，
he's long beard i think he's called they all have these great names, actually. So this invasion of Central Asia and then Khorasan is probably the most devastating. I mean, it does an enormous amount of damage. And it is, in effect, a punitive raid on a grand scale. I mean, there's a wonderful account when he takes Bukhara, he initially going into center. So actually, let me rein back a bit there. So the Khwarizm Shah, having insulted Genghis Khan to this sort of extent, then decides that it's not worth fighting him in battle, because it's a bit worrying. So he retreats into his cities and his castles and so on and so forth. Bad idea. I mean, very bad idea. He's stuck in his and basically flees. His son actually does a bit of fighting, but eventually is defeated and flees to India, actually. But it's and also in a very dramatic way. But what Genghis Khan does when he takes Bukhara, there's a famous account of him in Juvaini in particular, where he goes up to the minaret in Bukhara, having taken it. And he has this account where he says, you know, you basically it's, it's the Muslim justification says you have sinned,
你们的人民犯罪了。我怎么知道你们犯罪了？因为我在这里，基本上。我是你们的惩罚。如果你们没有犯罪，我根本就不会在这里。”所以这是对正在发生的事情的一种事后正当化。
you know, your people have sinned. How do I know you've sinned? Because I'm here basically. And I'm your punishment. And if you hadn't sinned, I wouldn't be here basically. So he's sort of retrospective justification of what's going on.
关于布哈拉的那个轶事的意义在于，他实际上进入了这座城市。是的。这意味着他通常不会进入城市。我的意思是，这也是一个有点杜撰的故事，从某种意义上说，有些人说，他会走上去发表那番言论的想法，似乎实际上是后来的波斯历史学家进行的润色，他们试图解释：“我们怎么会遭遇这场彻底的灾难？那一定是因为我们全都犯了罪。”另一个我想问的问题是，如果它是杜撰的，那么据说当他攻占其中一些地方时，比如讹答剌（Otrar），是的，他杀死了所有平民，是的，或者其中的很大一部分，其余的人被卖为奴隶。人们被处决的方式是
And the significant thing about that anecdote about Bukhara is that he's actually gone into the city. Yes. Which implies that normally he doesn't normally go into cities. I mean, again, it's a slightly apocryphal story in the sense that some people say, the idea that he would have gone up and made that statement seems to be really an embellishment of later basically Persian historians saying, how do we explain this complete catastrophe that has befallen us? It must be because we've all sin all sinned well another thing that i want to ask about is if it's apocryphal so it is said that when he takes some of these places otra for example yeah he kills all the civilians yeah um or a lot of them the rest of them are sold into slavery um people are executed
将熔化的白银灌入他们的耳朵和眼睛之类的地方。所以这些故事是被夸大了，还是你认为其中有一些真相？嗯，我认为有些是。我的意思是，有些经过了润色，听起来更有戏剧性，但有些确实发生了。所以，这两座城市——我认为真正遭受重创的——我的意思是遭受了极坏打击的，实际上是呼罗珊，它基本上承担了这次打击的主力。成吉思汗所做的是，他派他的儿子——我想是他的小儿子拖雷（Tolui）去处理呼罗珊。而且，可以说，征服者的儿子的心狠手辣程度甚至更甚——他没有经历过什么艰难的成长环境，
by having silver melted silver poured into their ears and eyes and things like that. So are these stories exaggerated or do you think there's some truth in them? Well, I think some of them are. I mean, some of them are embellished to make them sound more dramatic, but some of them are. So the two cities, I think, that really suffer, I mean, suffer very badly, are actually, it's Khorasan that basically gets the brunt of this. And what Gengis han does he sends his son i think his younger son tolui to deal with horasan uh and you know arguably that the children of the conqueror are even less you know he didn't have a troubled upbringing really
所以他没有那么同情心。梅尔夫（Merv）是其中的一座城市，据我所了解——我的意思是，再次取决于你认为这些城市在1220年或1221年左右有多大。但假设，例如，腹地的许多人为了寻求庇护而涌入城市，你可以想象这些城市的总人口基本上呈爆炸式增长。梅尔夫基本上被夷为平地。我的意思是，其中有趣的一点是，甚至今天的考古学家去那里时，也会意识到梅尔夫再也没有恢复过来。我的意思是，它从来没有从那场灾难中恢复过来。他们不仅把它夷为平地，还处决了所有人。
so uh he's he's less compassionate um marav is one of the cities which i understand i mean again it depends how big you think these cities were in sort of 1220 or 1221. But assuming, for instance, that a lot of people from the hinterland would have gone into the city for protection, you can imagine the population of these cities had been sort of basically ballooned up. Mariv was basically flattened. I mean, that, in one of the interesting, I mean, even archaeologists today going there, they'd realize that Mariv never recovers. I mean, it never recovers from it. Not only do they flatten it, they execute everyone.
通常他们会这样做——这也是一件相当令人震惊的事情，从某种意义上说——在击败这座城市之后（内沙布尔是另一座城市），他们基本上给每个蒙古战士分派了400人去处决。我的意思是，他们基本上就是这么干的。就像对待羊群一样？是的。他们把人带出来，然后说：“好了，你们每个人都会分到400人。”他们保留了——我想在其中一个案例中，他们保留了400名工匠，留作各种用途和演员，显然还有其他用途，为了他们的娱乐和利益。但除此之外的所有人基本上都被消灭了。这是真的吗？我的意思是，证据是
And normally what they do, and this is also quite, again, a shocking thing in a sense, is after the defeat of the city, there and Nishapur was the other one, they basically allocate to every Mongol warrior gets 400 people to execute. I mean, that's basically what they do. So like sheep? Yeah. They bring them out and they say and they say right you know you're all going to get 400 they keep i think in one case they kept you know 400 artisans that they were going to keep for various and actors obviously and and other things for their for their enjoyment and and benefit but everyone else is basically obliterated and they shall fall is that true i mean the evidence is
是的，我的意思是考古证据也倾向于……那么，我们是在讨论数以百万计的人吗？因为这就是人们所谈论的……嗯，人们谈论数以百万计的人被杀。我不认为……我不认为你可以现实地说，在一座城市里有一百万人被杀。我的意思是，我不知道——中国的人口显然比你在这里能找到的要庞大得多。但这些都是非常大的城市，对吧？我的意思是，这就是问题所在。所以我们的许多听众——某种英美听众——会觉得，嗯，这是偏远的不毛之地。但这里是中亚。
yeah i mean the archaeological evidence also tends to so are we are we talking millions because that's how that's what people talk about well people talk millions are killed i don't think i don't think you can realistically say that you know a million people are killed in a single city i mean i don't know that china the population of china is obviously vaster than what you're going to find here these are very big cities though aren't they i mean this is the thing so a lot of our listeners sort of anglo-american listeners yeah we'll I mean, this is the thing. So a lot of our listeners, sort of Anglo-American listeners, will be like, well, this is the back of beyond. But this is Central Asia.
这些是现在的前苏联中亚共和国，土库曼斯坦、乌兹别克斯坦等等。它们是非常精致、富有、繁荣的地方。我的意思是，我肯定会把人口估计在几十万。我的意思是，在其中一些情况下。特别是如果你考虑到腹地，
These are what are now the former Soviet republics of Central Asia, Turkmenistan, Uzbekistan, and so on. And they are incredibly sophisticated, rich, successful places. I mean, I would certainly put the population at several hundred thousand. I mean, in some of these cases. So particularly if you think of the hinterland certainly put the population at several hundred thousand. I mean, in some of these cases. So particularly if you think of the hinterland and all the people rushing into the city.
以及所有涌入城市的人。所以如果你说他们除了400名工匠外杀死了所有人，我的意思是，他们实际上是在杀死——我不知道——40万人。在我看来，我的意思是，再次，
So if you're saying that they kill everybody apart from 400 artisans, I mean, they're literally killing, I don't know, 400,000 people. It seems to me, I mean, again,
你知道，我们可以肯定地说……而且顺便问一句，我们这里只讨论了两座城市，因为大多数其他城市后来都选择投降了。而且，阿里，另一个著名的传闻是头骨金字塔，是的。嗯，他们再次说，他们把女性和男性的头骨分开，然后把它们堆叠起来，还有儿童……说实话，头骨金字塔更多是归属于帖木儿（Tamerlane）的东西，是的。那是帖木儿——如果是关于帖木儿的另一个播客，他基本上是在试图模仿成吉思汗，
you know, let's say certainly, and i mean we're only talking about two cities here by the way because most of the other cities then submit surrender and also ali the other famous thing is the pyramids of skulls yeah well they again they say that that they separate the women the female and the male skulls and they build them up and the children be honest the pyramid of skulls is more something attributed to tamerlane yeah it's and that's when tamerlane if for a separate podcast over tamerlane was basically trying to emulate jengis han yeah yeah right he was oasis to
你知道，所以他试图更胜一筹。我的意思是，我们的一个听众加文·格里菲斯（Gavin Griffith）说：“如果他杀死了历史书上说的那么多的人，那所有的骨骼都去哪儿了？”我想一些历史学家也说过类似的话，对吧？他们期待看到更多的大型墓穴。他们会期望看到某种屠杀规模的考古证据。它可能被润色了，为了……但润色这符合所有人的利益。这是一个敌对的……
you know so he was trying to go one better i mean one of our listeners uh gavin griffith said uh if he killed as many people as the history books say where are all the skeletons and i think some historians have said this, haven't they? They expect more mass graves. They would expect some sort of archaeological evidence of a slaughter on this scale. And it may have been embellished, you know, to... But it's in everyone's interest to embellish this in a way. It's an opposing...
我认为数以百万计的说法……数百万人，当人们谈论时——我的意思是，我听说过诸如4000万之类的数字。我的意思是，我认为这太夸张了。我认为完全……你知道，在蒙古帝国存在期间，在各种战役中有四到五百万人被屠杀是完全可能的。我的意思是，这并非不可能。如果你在谈论这些城市，比方说，对梅尔夫的一个保守估计将是20万、25万人。内沙布尔（Nishapur）当时是一座主要城市。它
I think the sort of millions and millions is... The millions, you know, when people talk... I mean, I've heard something as a 40 million or something. I mean, I think that's excessive. I think it the millions, you know, when people talk, I mean, I've heard something as a 40 million or something. I mean, I think that's excessive. I think it's entirely, you know, possible during the duration, certainly of the Mongol Empire that, you know, four to five million people would have been slaughtered in various campaigns. I mean, it's not impossible. If you're talking about these cities, let's say a conservative estimate for Marav would be 200,000, 250,000. Neshapur was a major city at the time. It has
再也没有恢复过来。我的意思是，它从来没有恢复过来。当然，人们会说，好吧，你知道，万人坑在哪里？我的意思是，我并不是说对内沙布尔或梅尔夫进行了大量的考古工作，梅尔夫的工作做得多一些，但还不足以真正了解发生了什么。而且显然，内沙布尔——你知道，关于内沙布尔的故事是，我想成吉思汗的女婿在战斗中意外身亡。城头上的某个人射出了一箭，成吉思汗的女婿被杀死了。因此他们对他的遗孀说：“你想要什么报复？”她说：“我要这个地方所有人死去。”
never recovered. I mean, it's never recovered. And of course, people say, well, you know, where are the mascots? I mean, I'm not saying there's been a huge amount of archaeological work done on Neshapur or Marv, there's been more, but not enough really to see what's going on. And obviously, but Neshapur, you know, the story with Neshapur is that I think Genghis Khan's son-in-law is accidentally killed. Someone on the battle think Genghis Khan's son-in-law is accidentally killed. Someone on the battlements fires an arrow and the son-in-law of Genghis Khan is killed. And therefore they say to his widow, you know, what is your retribution? She says, I want the place, everyone dead.
不仅是所有人，还有狗、猫，所有东西都被屠杀。就像罗马人做的那样。所以，你知道，因此我不想——我认为人们有一种试图修正蒙古破坏规模的倾向。我不会这么做。我的意思是，我认为即使是当时的人也感到震惊。但100万或200万的数字显然是夸大了。我不认为这些城市当时有100万或200万人口。我的意思是，那太多了。好吧，我们在那里稍作休息，一切顺利的话，我们一会儿见。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。所以，阿里，我的意思是，整件事就是，当侮辱发生时，报复是迅雷不及掩耳的。所以在梅尔夫，他们实际上抓获了一些蒙古人并让他们游街示众，对吧？是的，是的，不，这非常糟糕。因此，这个教训随后开始——是的，开始向南蔓延到伊斯兰帝国、阿拔斯帝国，向西蔓延到罗斯，并最终蔓延到拉丁欧洲，那就是：你选择投降。或者面临一切。
And it's not just everyone, it's dogs, cats, everything is slaughtered. As the Romans did. So that, you know, so again, I wouldn't want to, you know, I think people, there's an attempt to, I suppose, you know, revise the scale of the Mongol devastation. I wouldn't. I mean, I think certainly even people at the time were shocked. But figures of one or two million are obviously an exaggeration. I don't think these cities were one or two million. I mean, that's too much. OK, let's take a quick break there and we will see you back it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So, Ali, I mean, the whole thing is that when insults are
嗯，这就是赫拉特（Herat）市所做的。因此，赫拉特市听说内沙布尔的遭遇后，立即选择了投降。这就没事了。但是，你知道，他们还有另一件事——这就契合了汤姆的观点，当然——那就是他们有一种……你知道，他们有点认为这是一波部落掠夺者，他们进来，大肆破坏，然后就会滚蛋。一旦他们滚蛋了，我们就可以恢复正常。但有时会发生的情况——同样这也在历史记录中——是他们会派出一小队人马折返回来，仅仅是为了检查他们是否杀光了所有人。是的，我的意思是，你知道的，有一些骇人听闻的案例，人们从他们的洞穴之类的地方出来说：“哦，现在一切都好了，他们可以滚蛋了。”然后突然一队蒙古侦察部队出现，说：“啊，哈，”然后基本上彻底消灭了剩下的人。但有趣的是，在早期阶段，这是一次大规模的惩罚性远征，但它是如此具有毁灭性，以至于没有什么能真正取代它。因此，当成吉思汗的继承人最终进入并建立统治时，
done, then retribution is swift so at Merv isn't it right that they actually capture some of the Mongols and parade them through the streets yeah yeah yeah no it's terribly bad yeah and so the lesson which then starts to kind of yeah starts to ripple southwards to um to the Islamic empire to uh to the Abbasid empire and westwards towards Rus and then ultimately Latin Europe, is that you surrender. Yeah. Or everything.
你知道，他们基本上能够更容易地迁入。没有什么能够真正取代那个被击败的王朝。在这个阶段……
Well, that's what the city of Herat does. So the city of Herat hears what happens to the Nisropor and immediately submits. And it's fine. But, you know, the other thing that they have, and this goes to Tom's point, of course, is that there's a sort of, you know, they sort of think it's a wave of tribal
为了——我知道我们说过不谈论他，但让我们把亚历山大大帝的类比拉回来。好的。所以，亚历山大不断地前进、前进、前进，他显然在某种程度上对征服的刺激、攻占城市的期待等等上瘾了。为什么铁木真、为什么成吉思汗要一直前进？为什么——我的意思是，没有任何时候他会想：“好吧，这就是我的帝国了，你知道，管理它会非常有趣，建设水利工程、组织关税和税收。”显然，他没有这么想，他只是不断前进。你认为他曾经有可能停下来吗？
marauders they come in they wreak havoc and they'll bugger off and once we bugger off we can sort of get back to normal that what the what on occasion happens and again it's in the historical record is that what they do is they send parties back just to check that they got everyone yeah i mean this is you know and and there are some horrendous cases of you know people coming out of their sort of caves and stuff say oh it's all all right now where they can sod off. And then suddenly a party of, you know, Mongol reconnaissance force comes out and say, ah, you know, and basically, you know, finish off what's left. But it's interesting at this early stage, it is a massive punitive raid, but it's so destructive, actually, that nothing really replaces it. So that when ultimately successors of Genghis Khan come in to establish government,
嗯，这里有趣的地方在于他没有停下来。我的意思是，他实际上非常渴望回到中国。我的意思是，那才是他真正想要作为目标的。但这里发生的一件事——对我来说，这是你所能见到的最令人惊愕的军事历史片段之一——就是他有一个副将（用“副将”这个词其实不太准确，但无论如何），他的副将，比方说，叫速不台（Sube'etei），我必须说，这是我最喜欢的名字之一。速不台是他的主要副将之一，他被派出去——基本上，让我做一次武装侦查，看看远处的西方到底有什么。是的。他放手让他去。他们带了30,000名战士出发。基本上的理由是找出
you know, they, they, they basically able to move in a lot more, more easily. There's nothing that really replaces the, you know, the,
这个花剌子模沙朝藏在哪里。所以他们穿过里海等等。但随后他基本上——有趣的是，我们之前讨论过——吉本（Gibbon）基本上说过，这是历史上最非凡的军事成就之一。速不台带着30,000人，在里海南部呼啸而过，穿过高加索山脉，基本上击败了他遇到的所有对手，径直深入基辅罗斯，并在那里击败了他们。尽管这并非完全是一边倒。他最终确实击败了他们，但他靠的是智谋，因为区区30,000人是做不成什么大事的。但基本上他在三年后进行了这次完整的远征，然后几乎准时地加入了返回蒙古和中国的蒙古主力部队。我的意思是，这是一次非凡的武装侦查。如果允许我这样说的话，蒙古人可能是唯一在冬天成功入侵俄罗斯的人，他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们把河流、冰冻的河流当作了道路。阿里，那是他们俘获莫斯科公国的各个王公的时候吗？不，不是在这个时候。
the dynasty that was, was defeated. And at this stage. So to, I know we said we wouldn't talk about him, but let's bring back the parallel with Alexander. Okay. So,
那个曾经存在的王朝被打败了。在这个阶段，我想我们说过不谈论他，但让我们再次引入与亚历山大的对比。好的，所以，
so Alexander keeps going and going and going, and he's obviously addicted to some extent to the thrill of conquest and, you know, the expectation of capturing cities and all that. Why does Temujin, why does Genghis Khan keep going? Why doesn't, I mean, there's no, there's no, at no point does he think, okay, this is my empire now, you know, running it is going to be really interesting, building waterworks and organising tariffs and taxes. I mean, obviously, he doesn't think that and he just keeps going. Do you think there was ever a possibility that he might have stopped? Well, the interesting thing here is that he doesn't, I mean, he's actually quite keen to get back to China. I mean, that's what he really wants to target. But one of the things that
亚历山大不断地前进、前进、前进，他显然在某种程度上对征服的刺激、你知道的，对攻占城市的期待等等上瘾了。为什么铁木真，为什么成吉思汗还要继续前进？为什么，我的意思是，从来没有哪个时刻他会想，好吧，这现在是我的帝国了，你知道的，管理它会非常有趣，修建水利工程、组织关税和税收。我的意思是，很显然他没这么想，他只是不断前进。你认为他有没有可能停下来过？嗯，这里有趣的是他并没有，我的意思是，他实际上非常渴望回到中国。我的意思是，那才是他真正想把目标对准的地方。但发生在这里的事情之一，
happens here, which is, for me, one the most astonishing uh bits of military history that you'll ever that you'll ever see is the he has this lieutenant the lieutenant being the wrong word really but anyway his deputy let's say called sobriety one of my favorite names ever i have to say uh sobriety is one of his sort of chief lieutenants who he sends off who he basically, let me do a reconnaissance in force and see what the hell is out there further west. Yeah. And he lets him go. They take 30,000 warriors. They go, basically, the argument is to find out
对我来说，这是你所能见过的最令人震惊的军事历史片段之一，他有一位中尉——中尉这个词其实不太准确，但不管怎样，姑且称之为他的副手，名叫速不台（Sobriety，注：应为Subutai），我必须得说，这是我最喜欢的名字之一。呃，速不台是他的高级副将之一，他被派出去，基本上，让我去进行一次武力侦察，看看西边到底有什么鬼东西。是的。他放手让他去。他们带了三万名勇士。他们去，基本上，其目的是去找出
where this Khwarezm Shah is hiding. So they go through the Caspian and whatever. But he then takes essentially, and interestingly enough, we were talking about this earlier, Gibbon is the one who basically says it's one of the most extraordinary bits of military achievement in history. Sobhidai takes 30,000 men, goes careering around the southern Caspian, up through the Caucasus, basically beats everything
这个花剌子模沙（Khwarezm Shah）藏在哪里。所以他们穿过了里海等等。但随后他基本上采取了——有趣的是，我们之前讨论过这一点，吉本基本上说过这是历史上最非凡的军事成就之一。速不台带着三万士兵，绕着里海南部疾驰，穿过高加索山脉，基本上击败了他所看到的
that he sees, straight up into Kievan Rus, defeats them there. Although it's not entirely, you know, it's not entirely one side. He does ultimately end up defeating them, but he does it through guile, because with 30,000 men, you're not going to do a huge amount but basically does this entire tour after three years and then joins the main mongol force returning back to mongolia and china almost on cue i mean it's and it's an extraordinary reconnaissance and force and if i may say so it's probably the you know the mongols are the only peoples to have successfully invaded russia in winter and they do that because they use the rivers the frozen rivers as roads and ali is that when they they capture the various princes of muscovy and uh not you know at this time they
一切，一直打到基辅罗斯，并在那里击败了他们。尽管这并非完全是一面倒。他最终确实击败了他们，但他靠的是智谋，因为凭三万兵力，你做不了太大的事情，但在三年后，他基本上完成了这次整个远征，然后几乎准时地与返回蒙古和中国的主力蒙古军队汇合。我的意思是，这是一次非凡的武力侦察，如果我可以这么说的话，蒙古人可能是唯一成功在冬天入侵俄罗斯的民族，他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们把河流、冰冻的河流当成了道路。阿里，那是他们俘虏了莫斯科公国的各个王公的时候吗？呃，你知道的，在这个时候他们
haven't i mean that's later that's under ogadai and and so it's under ogadai when they have the feast and they crush them to death yeah yeah that that's a yeah that and sobadai does that too i mean sobadai so this is basically his let's see what's out here you know because that's enough because that story that they uh listeners to the uh the 10 worst parties in history may remember that uh the abbasids treated the emmaids like this yeah and just like genghis khan treated um jemuka that you're not allowed to spill the blood of yeah someone of royal blood yeah so they they Abbasids treated the Umayyads like this. And just like Genghis Khan treated Jamukha, that you're not allowed to spill the blood of someone of royal blood. So they capture these princes, lay them out as a foundation,
不是 我的意思是那是后来的 在窝阔台时期 窝阔台时期他们举行了盛宴 然后把他们压死 对 对 对 对 那个是 拔都也是这么干的 我的意思是拔都 所以这基本上是他的 让我们看看这里有什么 你知道吗 因为这就够了 因为那个故事 那些听众 听了那个“历史上的十大最差派对”可能会记得 阿拔斯王朝就是这样对待伍麦叶王朝的 就像成吉思汗对待札木合那样 你不能流淌……你不能流淌王室成员的血 所以他们阿拔斯王朝就是这样对待伍麦叶王朝的。就像成吉思汗对待札木合那样，你不能流淌王室成员的血。所以他们抓住这些王子，把他们当成地基，
and then build a huge, great structure and have a feast on top of them. And they kind of get crushed to death. So fun times. Mstislav the Thleird of Kiev. That's how he meets his end, isn't it? He's crushed under the dining table. But they've got to Samara in Russia. They've got to Crimea on this expedition.
然后建造一座巨大的宏伟建筑，并在他们上面举行宴会。他们有点被压死了。真是欢乐的时光。基辅的姆斯季斯拉夫三世。他就是这样走向终结的，不是吗？他被压在餐桌底下。但他们已经到达了俄罗斯的萨马拉。他们在这个远征中到达了克里米亚。
I mean, for a sort of scouting expedition. It's extraordinary. It is absolutely extraordinary. I mean, for me, it's astonishing. They capture the Genoese trading post, don't they? I think they get in there. I mean, obviously, it's a reconnaissance he doesn't stay but but the point is is that it for me what's remarkable about it i mean let's think about we're talking about the 1220s he's still able somehow to do
我的意思是，对于一次类似于侦察的远征来说。这太非同寻常了。这绝对是太非同寻常了。我的意思是，对盘我来说，这令人震惊。他们占领了热那亚的贸易据点，不是吗？我想他们进去了。我的意思是，很明显，这是一次侦察，他没有停留，但关键是，对我来说，关于它的非同寻常之处在于——让我们想想，我们正在谈论1220年代——他不知怎么仍然能够做到
this and to rejoin the main mongol force almost on cue i mean this is what's remarkable about it it's not he gets lost and you know he goes back joins the mongol army and then they go back obviously to finish off to do what they're going to do in China. And that's when, obviously, some of the significant conquests are taking place. But Sopadai is an extraordinary figure. And of course, later on, under Ogedei, is the leader of the assault on Europe. episode perhaps but as you said they go back to china basically jingis's focus is on china but but particularly on um on the poor old tanguts well they who have what have they done if they had a rebellion the tango they've had a rebellion and it's such a stupid thing to do so john man who wrote a very good book on on jingis khan said of of the way that that uh jingis khan treated the tango so basically he he sweeps in i mean he annihilates them all the emperor goes to to beg for forgiveness he gets killed everybody gets killed that and he says that there is a case to be made that this was the first ever recorded example of attempted
这一点，并且几乎在契合点上重新加入了蒙古的主力部队 我的意思是 这就是它引人注目之处 它不是那种他迷路了 然后你知道他回去加入了蒙古军队 然后他们显然回去收尾 去做他们在中国要做的事情。也就是在那时，显而易见的是，一些重大的征战正在发生。但速不台是一个非同寻常的人物。当然，后来在窝阔台手下，他是进攻欧洲的统帅。也许可以作为一集来讲述，但正如你所说的那样，他们回到了中国，成吉思汗的重心基本上在中国，但尤其是对付……对付可怜的党项人。他们……他们做错了什么？党项人发生了一场叛乱，他们发生了一场叛乱，做这种事太愚蠢了；所以约翰·曼——他写了一本关于成吉思汗的非常好的书——在评价成吉思汗对待党项人的方式时说：基本上，他席卷而来——我的意思是，他把他们全歼了，皇帝去乞求宽恕，他被杀了，所有人都被杀了——并且他说，有理由认为这是有史以来记录的第一次企图
genocide it was certainly very successful ethnocide ali i don't know what you make of that um i mean i it there are certainly cases and there have been arguments that have been a number of uh peoples who they they sought, you know, eliminate. I'm not as keen as applying some of these modern terms anyway to this period. But on the other hand, I'm also not going to soften, I think, what was going on. I mean, this was, you know. Because the Tanguts do vanish, don't they? Yeah, I mean, there's all places that do essentially vanish.
灭绝种族的行为。这当然是非常成功的文化灭绝，阿里，我不知道你对此作何感想……我的意思是，当然有这样的案例，也有过这样的争论，有一些……他们试图消灭的民族。无论如何，我不太热衷于将其中一些现代术语应用到这个时期。但另一方面，我认为我也不会淡化当时正在发生的事情。我的意思是，这是……你知道的。因为党项人确实消失了，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，有些地方确实彻底消失了。
And, you know, one of the arguments about the cities and their attitude to cities is as nomads, they had no particular sentimentality about cities and actually thought them, as I said, as dens of iniquity. So, you know, in that they were sort of cleaning up. And, you know, similarly in terms of people who might have betrayed them or whatever. By this stage, of course, Tom, I mean, you know,
并且，你知道，关于城市以及他们对待城市的态度的争论之一是，作为游牧民族，他们对城市没有什么特别的温情，事实上正如我所说，他们认为城市是罪恶的巢穴。所以，你知道，在这方面他们是在清理。而且，你知道，对于那些可能背叛了他们或类似事情的人来说也是如此。到了这个阶段，当然，汤姆，我的意思是，你知道，
the view of themselves as destined to rule the world would have been fairly well established. So anyone rebelling, you know. Well, that raises a really interesting question, Tom, I mean, you know, the view of themselves as destined to rule the world would have been fairly well established. So anyone rebelling, you know. Well, that raises a really interesting question, Ali, because if we just sort of step back and think about the map, they've taken most of China or lots of China. Northern, yeah. They've got a dominion that goes all the way through Afghanistan, through Central Asia. They've been to Crimea. They've been to Crimea. They've been to Kiev.
他们将自己视为注定要统治世界的看法已经相当巩固了。所以任何人反叛，你知道……嗯，这就提出了一个非常有趣的问题，汤姆，我的意思是，你知道，他们将自己视为注定要统治世界的看法已经相当巩固了。所以任何人反叛，你知道……嗯，这就提出了一个非常有趣的问题，阿里，因为如果我们退后一步考虑地图，他们已经占领了中国的大部分或者很大一部分。北部，是的。他们拥有一个贯穿阿富汗、贯穿中亚的统治领域。他们去过克里米亚。他们去过克里米亚。他们去过基辅。
They've been up into Russia on the Volga. But is that an empire? I mean, are there any governing structures? Are there any systems of tribute and taxation? Are there the communications links and all that that we would regard as marking an empire? Or have they just been and gone? Well, Dominic, actually, that very question
他们一直到达了伏尔加河畔的俄罗斯。但那是一个帝国吗？我的意思是，那里有任何统治结构吗？有任何贡赋和税收制度吗？有我们认为是帝国标志的通信联络以及所有这些东西吗？还是他们只是去过然后又走了？嗯，多米尼克，实际上，正是这个问题
has been asked by Eric the Red Wang. What a wise person he is. Great name. And he says Genghis Khan rapidly conquered a huge swathe of Eurasia. Can we properly call his holdings an empire? I think at this stage, it's a tribal confederacy. And there are large parts of it that remain that
已经被红发埃里克·王问过了。他是一个多么睿智的人啊。好名字。他说成吉思汗迅速征服了欧亚大陆的一大片土地。我们能恰当地称他的领地为帝国吗？我认为在这个阶段，它是一个部落联盟。并且其中有很大一部分保持着
really throughout, even when you get to, you know, Kublai Khan and the others. It does develop, I mean, they do bring in administrators to run the thing for them, basically Persian and Chinese. I mean, that's, that's basically where the administrators come. But it is, it is a quintessential example of small government in practice, it has to be said, I mean, that you do not have a bureaucracy in the sense that we would understand it, except out know out certainly outside uh the chinese and persian sort of um uh conquests uh but it is it is essentially run through the family and the extended family and the blood brothers and others and and that's how it's run in particularly you know your favorite on the golden horde and obviously the yeah i was like i like if i have a horde i'd have a golden hoard. It's basically, you know, those are tribal confederacies. But it is, I think you can describe it as an empire. So in other words. I think at this stage, it's in the process of formation, I think is the way to look at it.
实际上自始至终，即使到了忽必烈和其他人统治的时候。它确实在发展，我的意思是，他们确实引进了行政人员来为他们管理这件事情，基本上是波斯人和中国人。我的意思是，那就是——那就是行政人员的来源。但它必须得说是一个精简政府实践的典型例子，我的意思是，你没有我们所理解的那种官僚机构，当然除了……除了中国和波斯的那种……呃……征服之外；但它基本上是通过家族、大家庭、血兄弟和其他人来管理的，这就是它的管理方式，特别是你最喜欢的金帐汗国，显然是……是的，我就像——如果我有一个汗国，我就会有一个金帐汗国。基本上，你知道，那些是部落联盟。但我认为你可以把它描述为一个帝国。所以换句话说。我认为在这个阶段，它正处于形成的过程中，我认为这是看待它的方式。
But if you're living in the empire. So in other words, when I go to any website or open any book about Genghis Khan, there was always a map. This is the Mongol Empire at the time of his death in 1227. And it's sort of all shaded. Is that an accurate, you think that's a fairly accurate reflection. So the people living in a given town in that place sort of said that the overlords now, I mean, they may never have seen them, but they will know the overlords now are these fellows from Mongolia. Well well it depends on you know
但如果你生活在这个帝国里。所以换句话说，当我访问任何网站或打开任何关于成吉思汗的书时，总会有一张地图。这是1227年他去世时的蒙古帝国。它带有某种阴影。你认为这是一个准确的、相当准确的反映吗？因此，生活在那个地方的某个城镇的人们可能会说，现在的领主——我的意思是，他们可能从未见过他们，但他们会知道现在的领主是来自蒙古的这些家伙。嗯……嗯，这取决于，你知道
what the mongols did obviously is they that so the death of jengis khan in 1227 it's basically the area we're talking about is still essentially the eurasian step right so that's the key thing isn't it i mean so they're not you know they're not actually into persia proper they're not into southern china um obviously if you're a peasant or whatever i mean perhaps the relationship you have is no different because you're still paying your taxes to your local lord. The fact is your local lord is then going upwards and eventually who's getting the benefit of that labor is obviously a Mongol warlord of some sort. Yeah. So there's a Mongol warlord on the ladder at the top. I think, you know, by the time that the histories are being written. So when Giovanni writes his history, and I think he
蒙古人做了什么，很明显，他们……所以在1227年成吉思汗死后，我们所谈论的地区基本上仍然是欧亚大草原，对吧？所以那是关键所在，不是吗？我的意思是，所以他们实际上并没有进入真正的波斯，他们没有进入中国南部……很明显，如果你是一个农民什么的，也许你的关系没有什么不同，因为你仍然在向你的当地领主交税。事实是，你的当地领主然后向上级交纳，最终从这些劳动力中受益显然是某种蒙古军阀。是的。所以阶梯顶端有一个蒙古军阀。我想，你知道，当历史被撰写的时候。所以当乔瓦尼写他的历史时，我想他
finishes it in 1260, he spent a decade writing it. And the fact that he goes to Karakorum to investigate the secret history and to write the history of the Mongols, the fact that he can go from Persia to Mongolia without being hassled, without being harassed, shows that this is a... So, I mean, Ali, you've put this in the broadest historical sweep. Essentially, the whole history of Eurasia, you could say, has been about the tension between settled empires and nomads beyond the limits of those empires. Those are the two ways in which humans, you know,
在1260年完成了它，他花了十年时间来写它。他前往哈喇林去调查秘史并撰写蒙古人的历史这一事实，他可以从波斯前往蒙古而没有受到刁难、没有受到骚扰，这表明这是一个……所以，我的意思是，阿里，你把这置于最广阔的历史视野中。基本上，欧亚大陆的整个历史，可以说是关于定居帝国与这些帝国边界之外的游牧民族之间的张力。人类就是通过这两种方式，你知道，
since the Iron Age have been able to live, since the domestication of the horse, so that people in the steppes can go vast distances. And when Genghis Khan dies, he's conquered northern China. That's right. But southern China, Song China, remains proof against him. India remains proof. Persia, the Abbasid Empire, and Latin Europe,
自铁器时代以来一直能够生活，自从驯化了马匹以来，草原上的人们可以行进广阔的距离。当成吉思汗去世时，他已经征服了中国北方。没错。但中国南方，南宋，仍然没有被他攻克。印度仍然没有被征服。波斯、阿拔斯帝国和拉丁欧洲，
and the Orthodox world. Yeah. The question that the Mongols face when Genghis Khan dies is, can they go beyond just being a steppe empire? Yeah. And actually absorb these very, very ancient, settled cities? And that, of course, is a question that we'll'll leave for another episode but not to give too much away yeah they do and what it is i mean you know what it is actually is a testament to jengis khan's charisma i mean it's it because you know what dominic was saying earlier are there sort of imperial structures government there aren't really you know i mean there isn't i mean there's a sort
以及东正教世界。是的。当成吉思汗去世时，蒙古人面临的问题是，他们能否超越仅仅成为一个草原帝国？是的。并且真正吸收这些非常非常古老、定居的城市？当然，这是一个我们留到下一集再去探讨的问题，不过为了不剧透太多——是的，他们确实做到了，并且它实际上是什么——你知道它实际上是什么吗？这是对成吉思汗个人魅力的证明，我的意思是，因为正如多米尼克刚才所说的那样，那里是否有某种帝国的结构、政府？其实并没有，你知道，我的意思是，并没有——我的意思是，有一种
of a a network uh but what it is is a testament to the charisma of this individual that his his successors, his sons and others will pursue it. You know, particularly in Iran or Persia, you know, the shattering of the Khwarezm shahs. Yes, it doesn't mean that there's a that the Mongols are in control of it, but it's a vacuum. It's a political vacuum, in a sense, for several decades until the Mongols then do come and take over in a more systematic way. But you're right. I mean, I think for me, it's the Mongol Empire is is is extraordinary case study. I mean, obviously viewed from afar, you know, a case study that is shows the power, the, you know, the extraordinary power of nomadic peoples, well-organized, with a charismatic leader, politically able, obviously, but with a charismatic leader
网络……但它是个人的个人魅力的证明，他的继承人、他的儿子和其他人将继续追求它。你知道，特别是在伊朗或波斯，你知道，花剌子模沙朝的粉碎。是的，这并不意味着蒙古人控制了它，但这是一个真空。在某种意义上，这是一个政治真空，持续了几十年，直到蒙古人随后到来并以更系统的方式接管。但你是对的。我的意思是，我认为对我来说，蒙古帝国是一个非同寻常的案例研究。我的意思是，显然从远处看，你知道，一个案例研究，展示了游牧民族的力量，那种非同寻常的力量，组织良好，拥有具有领袖魅力、政治上精明但拥有领袖魅力的领袖，
and how they can sort of basically express that power. It's a real sort of rebuttal, in a sense, to our standard notions of civilization, if I may put it that way, and, you know, urban centers and this sort of thing. You know, it's the largest contiguous land empire in history. I mean, it's almost beyond comprehension in some ways.
以及他们如何能够基本上表达这种力量。在某种意义上，这是对我们标准的文明观念的真正反驳，如果我可以这样表达的话，还有城市中心和诸如此类的东西。你知道，它是历史上最大连片的陆地帝国。我的意思是，在某些方面它几乎令人难以置信。
It doesn't last very long. I mean, the fact that it doesn't last very long ultimately is a sign that its institutional basis is obviously quite as much weaker. Let's go back to Genghis Khan, just finish him off. Sure. So there are different versions of his death. I'm just trying to work out how old he was. So he is... Quite old, isn't he?
它并没有持续很久。我的意思是，它最终没有持续很久的事实表明，它的体制基础显然要薄弱得多。让我们回到成吉思汗，把他的部分讲完。当然。所以关于他的死有不同的版本。我只是想弄清楚他当时有多大年纪。所以他……相当老了，不是吗？
Yeah, he's late 60s, probably. I thought he was 70s or so. Yeah, early 70s. Some people say he falls off his horse while hunting. Some people say he's been hit by an arrow, an affected wound. And there's even a story that he's been stabbed by one of his wives or concubines or something, a princess that he's castrated.
是的，他大概快70岁了。我以为他70多岁左右。是的，70岁出头。有人说他在打猎时从马上摔下来了。有人说他被一支箭射中，伤口感染了。甚至还有一个故事说他被他的某个妻子或妃子或某个他阉割过的公主刺伤了。
To castrate him. Yes. It's one of the stories. Great favourite of yours, of of yours of course tom yeah turns him into a eunuch um so so ali i mean basically we just don't know is that we don't know we we don't know we know i mean the arguments obviously about his and this is one of the great you know for the um indiana joneses of the world you know to try and find where the hell his tomb is um where his burial site is. He wants no sign. I mean, basically his request is, I don't want to, nobody should know where I am.
为了阉割他。是的。这是各种故事之一。当然是你非常喜欢的，你非常喜欢的，汤姆，是的……把他变成了一个宦官，嗯……所以阿里，我的意思是，基本上我们就是不知道，是这样吗？我们不知道，我们不知道，我们不知道，我们知道——我的意思是，关于他的……的争论显然是——这是印第安·琼斯式的世界的大问题之一，你知道的，去试图找到他该死的坟墓在哪里，他的埋葬地点在哪里。他不想留下任何痕迹。我的意思是，基本上他的要求是，我不想让任何人知道我在哪里。
And of course, you know, and I think it's in the, I don't know which film it's in, I think it's in the Omar Sharif film, actually, rather than the John Wayne film. You know,
当然，你知道，而且我想它在——我不知道它在哪个电影里，我想实际上是在奥马尔·沙里夫的电影里，而不是约翰·韦恩的电影里。你知道，
the scene of the sort of the funeral cortege going and anything that crosses the path of the funeral cortege is slaughtered, you know. So that they won't give away the location. Beast, animal you know animal human whatever so that nobody can bear witness to where that must be that can't be true well i mean the truth the only the only the only thing is it is true is we don't know where he's buried it'd be demented to have people chasing after a stoat or something to try and kill it i mean you sort of think i mean this is the thing with archaeology
葬礼队伍前行的场景，任何穿过葬礼队伍路线的东西都被屠杀了，你知道的。这样他们就不会泄露位置。野兽、动物，你知道，无论是动物还是人类，这样就没有人能够见证那个地方可能在哪里——那不可能是真的吧？好吧，我的意思是，真相——唯一——唯一——唯一的事实是它是真的，我们不知道他被埋在哪里。去追赶一只白鼬或类似的东西试图杀死它，这简直太疯狂了，你会想——我的意思是，这就是考古学的问题所在
that with aerial record you know sort of the area you I mean, you sort of think, I mean, this is the thing with archaeology that with aerial, you know, sort of the area you might sort of see where the land has been disturbed or whatever. But it is interesting that there's just absolutely, we don't really know. I mean, we just- I was reading about this. I don't know whether this is true,
通过航空记录，你知道……某种区域，你——我的意思是，你会这么想，我的意思是，这就是考古学的问题所在，通过航空，你知道，某种区域，你可能会看出土地在哪里被扰动过或类似的情况。但有趣的是，真的完全没有，我们真的不知道。我的意思是，我们只是……我读过关于这个的报道。我不知道这是否属实，
that there's a kind of holy mountain. Really? That's very associated with Genghis Khan's life and death. And it is widely thought that he was buried on the sunny side the sunny slope of this mountain and that um expeditions keep not digging there and the implication is is that quite a lot of these expeditions that are kind of sent by Chinese or Japanese companies are actually prospecting you know they're kind of they're looking for minerals or whatever and
那就是有一种所谓的圣山。真的吗？那与成吉思汗的一生和死亡息息相关。并且人们普遍认为他被埋葬在这座山的向阳面、向阳坡上，并且……呃……探险队一直没有在那里挖掘，暗示是由中国或日本公司派遣的相当多的这些探险队实际上是在进行勘探，你知道的，他们是在寻找矿物或类似的东西，
that there's a kind of agreement with the mongolian authorities that they won't desecrate um the likeliest place where he's he's uh he's lying because of course uh jinkis khan now in mongolia is i mean he's almost dare i say a sacral figure yes absolutely i mean he's he's the father of the nation well but more than that i mean he's he's a religious figure he's he's seen as someone who is a kind of interface between the divine and the mortal. So he has this incredible kind of resonance. I mean, there's a wonderful, from Matt Yuki, who said, in Ulaanbaatar, I sat in the Genghis Khan pub on Genghis Khan street,
并且与蒙古当局有一种协议，他们不会亵渎他安息的最有可能的地方，因为当然……成吉思汗现在在蒙古，我的意思是——我甚至敢说他几乎是一个神圣的人物。是的，绝对的，我的意思是——他是国父。好吧，不仅如此，我的意思是——他是一个宗教人物，他被视为某种神圣与凡人之间的接口。所以他有着不可思议的共鸣。我的意思是，马特·尤基曾说过一段精彩的话，在乌兰巴托，我坐在成吉思汗大街上的成吉思汗酒吧里，
eating a Genghis Khan burger and drinking Genghis Khan vodka. Of course, I mean, the thing is, he was a teetotaler. I mean, he didn't drink. The Mongols drank heavily. I mean, they drank this, you know, was it fermented mare's milk? Fermented mare's milk, which is called Arak, which every sort of like vodka that we have in Central Asia is called Arak. But they, Kumis, I mean, but interestingly, Genghis Khan himself was a teetotaler kublai khan and the others on the other hand drank heavily i mean every day was a massive drunk i mean they know i mean all the ilkhan it interestingly in iran basically were alcoholics i mean it was that bad uh but i i think the the mongol mongolian
吃着成吉思汗汉堡，喝着成吉思汗伏特加。当然，我的意思是，事情是这样的，他是一个滴酒不沾的人。我的意思是，他根本不喝酒。蒙古人酗酒得很厉害。我的意思是，他们喝这个，你知道，是叫发酵马乳吗？发酵马乳，被称为阿剌克酒，中亚的每一种类似于伏特加的东西都叫阿剌克酒。但他们……库麦斯，我的意思是，但有趣的是，成吉思汗本人是滴酒不沾的，而忽必烈和其他人则酗酒得很厉害，我的意思是，每一天都是一次疯狂的烂醉，我的意思是，他们知道——我的意思是，所有的伊儿汗国，有趣的是，在伊朗基本上都是酒鬼，情况就是那么糟糕，呃……但我认为蒙古……蒙古
government brought out a vodka you know called you know Genghis Khan vodka. And someone pointed out that actually, I mean, since he never drank, that's wholly inappropriate. But, you know, they want to make the most, obviously, of the legacy. And there've been some other films that have been made and whatever that obviously look at his rise
政府推出了一种伏特加，你知道，叫做“成吉思汗伏特加”。有人指出，事实上，既然他从来不喝酒，那是完全不合适的。但是，你知道，他们当然希望充分利用这份遗产。并且还有一些其他已经制作的电影和其他什么，显然审视了他的崛起，
and slightly, you know. And how should we remember him, Ali? Should we, I mean, how should we remember him? I mean, is he a figure of fable? Is he a historical figure? I mean, he obviously is a historical figure, but so much of what we think we know about him is on uncertain foundations.
并且稍微……我们该如何记住他呢，阿里？我们应该——我的意思是，我们该如何记住他？我的意思是，他是一个神话中的人物吗？他是一个历史人物吗？我的意思是，他显然是一个历史人物，但我们自以为关于他所知道的很多东西都建立在不确定的基础上。
But also, we in the 21st century are much more, I mean, by and large, we're much slower to embrace great men of history who have piled up pyramids of skulls than our predecessors would have been. So do you think, I mean, is it right that we remember him as this dreadful monster? Or do you think actually that's orientalizing and we're projecting a sort of, you know, this sort of idea of the Easter savage and all that?
而且，我们在21世纪更加……我的意思是，总的来说，与我们的前辈相比，我们更慢地去接纳那些堆砌着骷髅金字塔的历史伟人。所以你认为——我的意思是，我们把他记作这个可怕的怪物是正确的吗？还是你认为这实际上是东方主义，我们在投射一种……你知道的，这种关于东方野蛮人的想法以及所有这些？
Yeah, no, I mean, I think you have to just see him as a figure of his time, you know, in the sense of, but without, without you know sanitizing the whole thing and sort of trying to say that somehow he was a you know uh eco warrior of some sort or or you know it wasn't quite so bad and this sort of thing i mean it it's certainly true that i think some of the tropes about the mongols the horde being one of them by the way uh and also the sort of indiscriminate violence it wasn't actually indiscriminate violence, but it was violent. Yeah, it was targeted, but it was violent. I mean, you know, if you rebelled, that was it.
是的，不，我的意思是，我认为你必须把他看作一个时代的人物，你知道的，从某种意义上说，但没有……没有……你知道的，美化整件事，并试图说他不知何故是一个……某种生态战士，或者……或者你知道的，情况并没有那么糟糕以及类似的事情。我的意思是，这当然是真的，我认为关于蒙古人的一些陈词滥调——顺便说一句，其中之一就是“汗国”——还有那种无差别的暴力，它实际上并不是无差别的暴力，但它确实是暴力的。是的，它是针对性的，但它是暴力的。我的意思是，你知道，如果你反叛了，那就这样了。
And they struck terror. I mean, their use of terror was extremely sophisticated, if I can put it that way. So I think the whole experience, and I teach the Mongol Empire and stuff, you know, I always use the Mongol Empire as an excellent case study of, you know, what nomadic peoples can do. I mean, with charisma, with limited institutions, with, you know, it's almost antithetical to our understanding what an empire should be. And yet, it was, you know, the most extensive empire that in territorial terms certainly that the contiguous land empire certainly that we've seen um but it's also i mean it's interesting because of the whole discussion on empire of course people are much more uh comfortable in talking about the mongol empire if i can put it that way than they may be of other empires but the mongol empire is it you know the
并且他们散布了恐惧。我的意思是，他们对恐惧的使用极其老练，如果我可以这样表达的话。所以我觉得整个经历——我教蒙古帝国之类的东西，你知道——我总是把蒙古帝国作为一个极好的案例研究，关于游牧民族能做什么。我的意思是，凭借个人魅力、凭借有限的体制，凭借……你知道，这几乎与我们对帝国应该是什么的理解背道而驰。然而，它确实是……在领土意义上绝对是最广阔的帝国，连片的陆地帝国绝对是我们所见过的……但这也是……我的意思是，这很有趣，因为关于帝国的整个讨论，当然人们在谈论蒙古帝国时要舒服得多——如果我可以这样表达的话——比起他们对其他帝国的态度，但蒙古帝国是……你知道的，
mongol empire is really what everyone reacts against. Just to end this with three fields. Three fields. Three mighty fields. Three fields of science. And I can see Dominic's happy face light up. But obviously there's so much that we don't know about the early years of Genghis Khan and about the growth of the Mongol Empire and all that kind of thing. But that scientists have kind of shed light on
蒙古帝国实际上是每个人都反对的目标。就用三个领域来结束这个话题吧。三个领域。三个强大的领域。三个科学领域。我可以看到多米尼克高兴的脸亮了起来。但很明显，关于成吉思汗的早年生活、蒙古帝国的成长以及所有诸如此类的事情，我们还有很多不知道的，但科学家们已经阐明了
three distinct areas and one of them is a question that millions of people on the discord and on twitter asked so Oliver Mason is representative is it true that an enormous proportion of people currently alive share his DNA about one in ten I don't know that's interesting I've heard that I've heard that okay well so i asked uh adam rutherford very distinguished scientist uh knows all about this stuff uh and he and and uh how so i said you know how many of us are related to dingus khan he said not properly accounted for but the answer is in the millions he's long enough ago and had so many children that he acts as a near iso point like charlemagne yeah uh so um and then he's he's talking about the
三个不同的领域，其中之一就是成千上万在Discord和Twitter上的人所问的一个问题：奥利弗·马森是一个代表，目前活着的人中有很大一部分比例拥有他的DNA，大约十分之一，这是真的吗？我不知道，这很有趣，我听说过这个，我听说过这个。好吧——所以我问了亚当·卢瑟福——一位杰出的科学家，对这一切了如指掌——他和……所以我说，你知道我们当中有多少人与成吉思汗有亲缘关系？他说没有确切统计，但答案是数以百万计。他年代足够久远，又生了那么多孩子，以至于他就像查理曼大帝一样，充当了一个近同源点（iso point），是的。所以……然后他在谈论
iso point for europe being around at 1000 ad which means anyone who has living descendants from that time or earlier is the ancestor of all europeans and this always kind of makes my head explode anyone who lives in the number of 1000 ad is your ancestor i calculate that the chances that edward iii is not the ancestor of anyone today with British ancestry is 10 to the power of minus 21. So basically, yes, everyone in Eurasia
欧洲的同源点大约在公元1000年左右，这意味着任何在那个时候或更早有存活后代的人，都是所有欧洲人的祖先。这总是让我的大脑有点爆炸。任何生活在公元1000年左右的人都是你的祖先。我计算过，爱德华三世不是今天任何有英国血统的人的祖先的几率是10的负21次方。所以基本上，是的，据我理解亚当所说，欧亚大陆的每个人
is descended from Genghis Khan, as I understand, Adam. But I mean, that doesn't mean anything. It just means that we're descended from everybody who lived then. Dominic...
都是成吉思汗的后代。但我的意思是，这并不意味着什么。这只意味着我们是当时生活的每个人的后代。多米尼克……
Sorry, Tom, I don't want to... I don't know. I don't know. And then, Ali, this was the other one that you pointed out to me, which is,
抱歉，汤姆，我不想……我不知道。我不知道。然后，阿里，这是你向我指出的另一个，即
and you mentioned it just briefly back then. Dinkes Khan as eco warrior. Yeah. Well, there's been this again. You know, the question is, is was he a conscious eco warrior or not? I mean, there are some people that say, well, you know, his his demolition of cities and stuff was great for CO2 output. I mean, it's a robust policy yeah i mean you know uh in you know returning to nomadic ways of life is is rather good um extinction rebellion yes i mean it's it's uh again i i think this is yeah holy far-fetched and quite unreal i mean it's it's not something that would have crossed his mind um and uh but it's interesting that people try and you know well i don't know why you know they're
你在刚才简短地提到了它。成吉思汗作为生态战士。是的。好吧，这里再次出现了。你知道，问题是，他是有意识的生态战士还是无意识的？我的意思是，有些人说，好吧，你知道，他对城市的破坏等等对二氧化碳排放量大有裨益。我的意思是，这是一个强有力政策，是的，我的意思是，你知道，呃，你知道，回归游牧生活方式是相当不错的。灭绝叛乱，是的，我的意思是，它……再次，我认为这……是的，太牵强了，而且很不真实，我的意思是，这不是会掠过他脑海的事情，并且……但有趣的是人们试图……你知道……好吧，我不知道为什么，你知道，他们决心要……显然要找到一些积极的事情来说……但你知道，我认为关于成吉思汗和蒙古人有大量、有大量有趣的事情可说——我的意思是，我认为他们很迷人——但生态战士主义、环保主义并不是其中之一。所以为了公平起见，我正在阅读你发给我的研究。它是来自卡内基科学研究所全球生态学部门的。它于2011年问世。它得出的结论是，成吉思汗单枪匹马地从大气中清除了7.0亿吨碳。我知道，确实如此。我的意思是，这太棒了。我的意思是，我可以看出他在这么做的时候进行了计算。所以为了把这放在视角中，这大约是通过汽油一年产生的二氧化碳量。哇。通过汽油消耗。
determined to you know obviously to find something positive to say um but you know i think there's huge amounts there's huge amounts of interesting things to say about jingis khan the mongols i mean i i think they're fascinating but eco warrior environmentalism isn't one of them so just to be fair and i'm reading the study that you sent me. It's from the Carnegie Institution's Department of Global Energy. It came out in 2011. And it concluded that Genghis Khan single-handedly scrubbed 700 million tons of carbon from the atmosphere. I know, exactly. I mean, it's brilliant. I mean, I can see he was calculating that as he was doing it. So just to put that in perspective, that's about the quantity of carbon dioxide generated in a year through petrol. Wow. Through petrol consumption.
好的。然后是第三个，我认为非常有趣。在某些方面可能最有趣。是的。也就是这个观点：蒙古人在后来欧洲的黑死病中发挥了关键作用。通过土拨鼠，正如你所说。通过土拨鼠。所以细心的听众可能还记得，我们提到过铁木真当
Okay. And then there's the third one, which I think is really interesting. Which is probably the most interesting in some ways. Yeah. Which is this idea that the Mongols played a key role in what became the Black Death in Europe. Through the marmot, as you said. Through the marmot. So attentive listeners may remember that we mentioned how timogen when
他处于困境时，一直在吃土拨鼠——沦落到吃土拨鼠，而土拨鼠是一种啮齿动物，不是吗？没错，栖息在大草原上……它们是一种零食，它们——并且——并且——并且他们使用皮毛，所以蒙古人使用皮毛，因此当他们传播开来时，他们会把这些不幸的小啮齿动物作为零食或皮毛或类似的东西随身携带。结果证明，有四种不同菌株的腺鼠疫，所有这些菌株的发展，其轨迹都遵循四个不同方向的路线。是的，这很迷人，军队——所以这就是由莫妮卡·格林——我想她是一位历史学教授——提出并论证的论点，基本上由于他们向不同地区扩张的速度，你知道，他们随身携带了这种病毒——我对此假设唯一的疑问在某种程度上是，
he was on his uppers was um eating mark reduced to eating marmots and marmots are a kind of rodent aren't they that's right inhabits the step um and they're a kind of snack and they and and and and they use the skins so the mongols use the skins so they would have carried these unfortunate little rodents as snacks or as furs or whatever with them as they spread. And it's turned out that there are four distinct strains of bubonic plague, all of which follow their growth, follows the track lines of four different directions. Yeah, it's fascinating armies so that's that's the thesis presented by um argued by monica green who's a professor of history i think at and basically because of the speed at which they expanded into different areas you know they carried this sort of the the virus with them i mean the only question i have on that uh hypothesis in a sense is is to
蒙古人本身在多大程度上容易受到这种病毒的影响，你知道，受到鼠疫本身的感染。同样，我不知道，我真的不知道这个问题的答案，
what extent the mongols themselves were vulnerable to this sort of, to this virus, you know, to the, to the plague themselves. And again, I don't know, I don't know actually the answer to that really,
在某种程度上，但似乎他们在哪里——他们在哪里获得了免疫，并且只是，你知道，带着这些——这对我来说似乎是不合情理的。
in a sense, but it seems to be that where they, where they immune themselves and simply, you know, carrying these, these, these. That seems implausible to me.
是的，土拨鼠皮毛，你知道，带着它们走遍世界。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的答案，解开了为什么腺鼠疫似乎没有影响……的谜团。
Yeah. Marmot skins, you know, with them across, across the world. I mean, it is, it is a kind of interesting answer to the puzzle of why the bionic plague seems not to have affected um
印度。印度，是的。蒙古人从未攻击过印度。所以我的意思是，这是一个绝妙的论点，并表明也许有……你知道，我的意思是，它开启了一条全新的道路——我的意思是，真正获得吸引力的主要生态论点是——这个观点，你知道，是什么促使蒙古人走出去，你知道，基本上进行扩张？正如我们所讨论的，其中之一显然是成吉思汗的……你知道，他的政治动机，但另一个是基本上气候变暖了，这使得蒙古人能够繁殖更多的马匹，在平原上、草原上维持更多的马匹，但这也意味着他们基本上需要向外扩张。
india india yeah the mongols never attacked india so i mean it's a it's it's a great thesis and suggests that perhaps there are um you know i mean it opens up a whole avenue i mean the main the main eco argument really is uh that has gained traction is this idea that you know what was it that encouraged the mongols to go out you know to basically expand and one of those as we discussed is obviously jengis khan's um you know his political motivations but the other was that basically there was a sort of a warming of the climate which allowed uh for the mongols to breed much more horses to sustain many more horses on the plane on the steps but that what that meant also was they needed to basically expand outwards.
从某种意义上说，他们在那种意义上拥有了更多的战争能力。因为每个蒙古王战士去的时候，论点是他们有五匹马。所以他们带着五匹马旅行。所以当蒙古军队的一些数字如此庞大时，有些人说这反映了他们把每一匹马都计算在内了。所以如果你认为成吉思汗带着十万大军入侵呼罗珊，我的意思是，你谈论的是五十万——哦，从后勤角度考虑，它其实非常庞大，对吧？我们应该回到后来蒙古人的问题上来，不是吗？
They had a lot more capacity for warfare, in a sense, in that sense. Because each Mongol warrior goes, the argument was they had five horses. So they traveled with five horses. So when some of the figures for Mongol hordes are so vast, and some people say that reflects the fact that they're counting every horse. So if you think that Genghis Khan invaded Khorasan with a hundred thousand men I mean you're talking about then five hundred thousand oh it's huge actually when you think about it in terms of logistics right we should return shouldn't we to the issue of the later
蒙古人的问题以及蒙古帝国的建立——是的，帝国以及对欧洲的进攻，我的意思是，因为那是一个绝对迷人的主题。这是伟大的，我的意思是，我们谈论了太多历史上的“如果”。当然，那是伟大的“如果”之一，不是吗？如果蒙古人继续前进会怎样，或者也许他们无法继续前进？好吧，我们可以改天再讨论这个，阿里。
Mongols and the creation of the Mongol empire yeah the empire and the attack on Europe I mean because that is an absolutely fascinating subject. And it's the great, I mean, we've talked so much about what-ifs in history. And of course, that is one of the great what-ifs, isn't it? What if the Mongols had kept going or maybe they couldn't have kept going? Well, we can discuss that another time, Ali.
不要回答那个问题。因为我们要在这里呆上好几个小时。而汤姆只会试图以某种方式把科学重新拉进讨论中，然后我又会睡着。好吧，拜托，多米尼克。这真的很有趣。是的，很迷人。
Don't answer that question. Because we'll be here for hours. And Tom will just try to drag science back into it in some way and I'll fall asleep again. Right. Oh, come on, Dominic. That's really interesting. Yeah, fascinating.
没有比这更有趣的了。你知道我喜欢科学聊天，汤姆。我是，我是。好吧。阿里，非常感谢你。太棒了。谢谢。真的很享受。
It doesn't get more interesting than that. You know I love a scientific chat, Tom. I do, I do. Right. Ali, thank you so much. That was brilliant. Thank you. Really enjoyed it.
一杯烈性的发酵熊奶。是的，我想向我在圣安德鲁斯的学生们大声喊话，多姆。哦，好吧，我们总是很高兴。我自己也是一名前圣安德鲁斯学生，阿里。所以我们总是很高兴有圣安德鲁斯学生在收听。他们加入了伯明翰爱德华国王学校的学生，J·R·R·托尔金的母校。如果你有一所学校你希望在
A stiff drink of fermented bear's milk. Yeah, I wanted to shout out to my students in St. Andrews, Dom. Oh, well, we're always happy. I'm a former St. Andrew's student myself, Ali. So we're always happy to have St. Andrew's students listening. They join the students of King Edward's Birmingham, JRR Stockings, Alma Mater. If you have a school that you would like to have mentioned
本期《历史的其余部分》中被提及，我们的费用非常适中。拜托，是的，联系我们的制作人，他们将很高兴讨论银行转账。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，呃，我们向阿里道谢，我们下次节目再见，再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听独家番外、抢先体验、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
on the rest of this history, our fees are very moderate. Please, yes, that our producers and they will be happy to discuss the bank transfer so on that bombshell uh we say thank you to ali and we'll see you all next time goodbye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
也就是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.